we all know that sea lions are great at
balancing things on their noses but
that's really selling them short sea
lions are in fact some of the oceans
most graceful and deft swimmers so much
so that scientists are picking a partner
locomotion to one day apply their
secrets to underwater vehicles sea lions
are incredible swimmers but they're also
weird swimmers most fish flick their
tails back and forth to power themselves
around while other marine mammals like
whales and dolphins flick there's up and
down but that won't do for the sea lion
it's actually pulling itself through the
water with its powerful front flippers
as opposed to pushing with its tail and
that grants an incredible
maneuverability so scientists at George
Washington University are looking at how
the c line is pulling this off
specifically they've been building Robo
flippers they do laser scans of sealine
flippers then use the data to 3d print
faithful replications in silicon by
attaching the new flipper to a robotic
arm if scientists can recreate sea lion
swimming in a tank and measure things
like drag and thrust they can also print
alternate versions of the flipper for
instance one without those
characteristic bumps along the edge to
see how that affects swimming efficiency
so what does this all have to do with
underwater vehicles well currently these
vehicles are big cumbersome if engineers
can design new varieties based on
sealine locomotion underwater vehicles
could get a lot stealthier and more
maneuverable and that'd be real useful
if you wanted to do something like
explore a watery minefield without
blowing up your ride